salut la team menthe à l'eau aujourd'hui
je suis avec riis alias poisson fécond
oui bloup bloup c'est moi on reconnaît
un petit peu le salon si ce n'est que
ces messieurs comment suivre mes vidéos
n'est ce pas c'était compréhensible ce
que tu as dit bah oui je n'enchaîne tard
je checke ma montre steampunk exactement
2h30 du matin j'avais l'impression de
malaise car lewis saxon usa sur les
monts les 2h30 du matin il en a trouvé
que c'était une très bonne idée d'en
profiter de ce moment est de 7 heures
pour parler du fait d'avoir des
problèmes pour s'endormir le soir donné
des clés ou des techniques ou des
conseils à ceux qui tournent et qui
vient de loin des heures dans leur lit
sans trouver le sommeil
il ya la snr la sms et un truc un petit
peu bizarre
donc c'était personnes qui chuchote qui
font des petits trucs comme ça il fera
des objets et c'est peut-être très
relaxant peut-être que vous y êtes
sensible à ce genre de choses et vous ne
le savez pas à les regarder
je fais donc quand tu parlais du verseau
enfin c'est justement ça que je fais de
sucer des vidéos de relaxation et
j'écoute très souvent ce genre de vidéo
presque tout le temps en fait avant de
m'endormir je mets ces vidéos et puis ça
m'aidera à faire dodo c'est
essentiellement le truc après il ya
l'hypnose prendre l'auto hypnose ou
alors vous reste tout alors il ya un
truc qui écoule aussi c'est que vous
comptez votre respiration de 3,4 je
retiens un deux trois quatre et ça finit
par nous paradoxe ou les entraînements
sont noirs alors la technique complet du
cas de 7,8 l'idée c'est de mettre la
langue
derrière ses incisives de bien la colle
au palais raffiné fait ou d'accords au
palais d injecter un capteur hockey une
fois que tu as fait ça pour le premier
coup bon tu vis de l'air de tes poumons
vous pouvez essayer de faire ça et
ensuite de bien inspiré par le nez en
comptant jusqu'à 4 mais vraiment une
fois par seconde une fois que c'est fait
de bloquer et de compter jusqu'à sept
et une fois que c'est fait d'expirer en
comptant jusqu'à 8 et par la bouche
toujours en ayant la langue des ensuite
d'excès on a expiré on va inspirer
exactement est à présent capable semaine
et qu'il n'y a pas de période
ah les poumons à vis des non il n'y a
pas de blocage en poumon vide et donc il
s'est enfui mon plein d'accord moi j'ai
connu d'autres trucs le 8 4 8-4
il ya eu 58 aussi le wimax est rien
ouais là le cas de 7,8
le but c'est l'oxygénation au contraire
c'est pour ça que c'est quand elle le
couple un d'accord et après comme ça ils
se chargent et tu peux tout l'idée d'un
jour voilà tous les chevaux et
l'oxygénation qui va améliorer les
rythmes cardiaques qui va vous faire du
bien vous pouvez signer ça c'est une
technique avait été découverte dans une
université américaine
la langue ça va paraître se concentrer
et si vous pratiquez régulièrement au
bout d'un moment en temps normal c'est
sur un cycle directement que vous allez
vous endormir parce que comme tu disais
très bien ça va te saouler un petit peu
et tu vas pas la technique vendu
commercialement parlant on te dit en une
minute tu dors avec sa mentalité
ok c'est pas et en picolant sinon il ya
aussi le recensement la technique soit
7,8 juste l'alcool ça peut marcher ou si
je suis fait apparaître le petit message
l'alcool est dangereux
tu peux le mettre partout parce que
quand je vais dire il faut que dans une
bouteille doit au moins servir ensuite
vous dormez directement bas après il ya
les ondes ajouter mon grain de sel bien
sûr ça faisait que les
et si on connaît pas les ondes alpha
donc le cerveau ils font qu'il est
calibré sur certains types d'ondés
bref il va se met à vibrer comme ça
comme un radio demain un marteau piqueur
en pique niqueurs un marteau piqueur
quand on a des tas devait y vivre comme
ça ensuite ça détend quand commence à
être l'axé et le marteau piqueur vivent
de moins en moins et les ondes alpha
c'est celle qui sont plus basses pour un
schéma parce que mon chien je ne
comprends un peu quand je parle après
sur des sur des chaussures sur des
conseils un petit peu plus pratiqué un
peu plus évident mais ça fait toujours
du bien de le rappeler en général on a
du mal à s'endormir près ce qu'on est
parasitée par les choses qu'on a à faire
par tout ce qu'on a en tête
oui par les idées qu'on à part le fait
de se coucher en se disant ah oui [ __ ]
faut aussi que je passe à demain ça
demain ça demain il ya une chose très
bête mais qui fonctionne bien c'est
avant de se coucher de se décharger sur
du papier
l'orgasme c'est fait ça on en a parlé
c'est bon ok de se télécharge entend
bien bruit de se décharger mentalement
sur du papier ans faisant une espèce de
to do list des choses qu'on à faire
qu'on a laissé en suspens avant d'aller
se coucher quand je commençais à ce qui
fait que j'étais mineure
bah oui enfin c'est voilà je me mets à
écrire des romans gaza il ya çà et là ça
ce qui fait qu'il ya 4 heures du matin
je suis toujours à écrire fatigue mais
parce que j'écris trop mais dans les
bons trop prolifique aussi je sais pas
du tout ce qu'elle va rendre cette vidéo
en termes d'énergie skies c'est à dire
en termes de dynamisme
ouais d'énergie tout court bangkok les
blancs est ce que vous allez on a
beaucoup parlé avec chris était
passionnant toute la journée toute la
soirée ce qui fait qu'on tourne très
tardivement et c'est super je me suis
abreuvé de conseils d'expérience et de
même petite anecdote à côté du sommeil
vous dormirez plus tard c'est que ce
cher collègue c'est que il
il après enfin je vois là je t'ai fait
visiter un petit peu grenoble notamment
les la forêt là où il n'y a pas de
lumière tellement glauque et pas de
lumière mon arrivée à voir les cadavres
de toutes les bouteilles et de papier
chelou et de tout ça autour de nous tu
t'en souviens encore c'est pas sa
fonction est fait voilà c'était un petit
panel de plein de techniques différents
de délits piste on peut en parler dans
les commentaires si vous vous avez
d'autres méthodes qui vous est de vous
endormir ou si vous voulez que je
reprenne un peu plus en détail notre
méthode je pourrais aussi vous répondre
dans l'est comme pour tout le monde
voilà sur le 4 7 8 sur autre chose vous
pouvez aussi aller voir sur la chaîne du
verso des choses qui sont très
intéressantes en terme de relaxation et
en plus de ça si vous n'avez pas pris
les vidéos depuis le départ vous devriez
pouvoir rattraper toute la chaîne dix
personnes s'est rapidement et ça wahou
comment tu me vends oui c'est beau non
mais voilà je n'ai pas grand chose à
dire d'autre ça vous donne pas mal de
petites pistes suggérées du mal à dormir
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la
chaîne avant de partir puisque le mental
boxe et une vidéo par jour pendant un an
merci beaucoup a fait ça c'est intense
et ça se solde
merci merci fabien c'est parce que je ne
savais pas encore que c'était compliqué
merci à christophe sont fait qu'on si le
hasard fait que vous ne connaissez pas
crise je vais vous mettre le un bandeau
cliquable ici tout le lien dans la
description cette fuite heures merci à
toi tu es là merci fabien d'un script
conservation et au développement et les
enfants c'est rien du tout là j'ai
l'impression de teruel merci au revoir
merci cm présent choisi le dodo à toi et
moi me voir je compte merci rendez vous
demain à 17h chao bisous l'école
oui